-♪ Kid Theater ♪
♪ Kid Theater ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
-Okay.
The first one is from Reese.
He is 9 years old.
Tom, you'll be playing
the role of Skeleton.
And I'll be playing
the role of Mummy.
Higgins will read
scene descriptions for us.
Higgins, please set the scene.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Duck, Duck, Goose!
-And scene.
And scene. Fantastic.
[ Laughs ] All right.
Here we go.
[ Laughs ]
A head bump. I know. All right.
All right. Let's do another one.
This next one was sent in
by Aaron. He's 7 years old.
For this one,
I'll play the role of Charlie.
And, Tom, you will be
the character The Mummy.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
Uh, Higgins,
set the scene, please.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-I love these.
I love these. Crazy.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Nom-nom-nom-nom!
[ Breathes deeply ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And scene.
That's the best. The best.
Let's do one more.
This last one here
was sent in by Lucy, who is 6.
I will be playing Sheep.
Tom, you'll again be playing
the role of Mummy.
-Okay.
-Higgins, set the scene, please.
-[ Hiccups ]
I have the -- [ Hiccups ]
hiccups.
-Why?
-[ Hiccups ] No clue.
[ Hiccups, hiccups ]
-[ Hiccups ]
-[ Hiccups, hiccups ]
-Oh, no! I caught
the mummy's hiccups!
[ Hiccups, hiccups ]
-[ Hiccups ] Hiccup!
-[ Hiccups, hiccups ]
-[ Hiccups ]
-Hiccup! Hiccup!
-[ Hiccups, hiccups ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Coughing ]
-[ Hiccups ]
We need to -- [ Hiccups ] --
drink some water.
I brought a cup of water
with me. [ Hiccups ]
-[ Hiccups, hiccups ]
-Here it -- Here it is.
[ Hiccups ] Here it is.
-[ Hiccups ]
-Here it is.
[ Laughter ]
-What do we clean
the water up with? [ Hiccups ]
-[ Hiccups ] Uh -- [ Hiccups ]
Me. [ Hiccups ]
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Hiccups ]
[ Snores, hiccups, hiccups ]
[ Snores, hiccups ]
-See you tomorrow. [ Hiccups ]
-[ Hiccups ]
-[ Hiccups ] Baa!
[ Hiccups ] Baa!
[ Hiccups ] Baa! [ Hiccups ]
And scene!
-Scene.
-That's what I'm talking about.
♪♪
-Double-handed bow.
Double-handed bow.
-Let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-My thanks to all
of our kid playwrights.
And thank you to Tom Cruise!
Check out "The Mummy"
opening everywhere on Friday.